[Applaudissements]
cette année les artistes ont fait le
show sur le plateau des victoires
regardez oui gilles verdez excusez moi
mais vous ça fait un petit moment que je
vous regarde
[Applaudissements]
question vous connaissez ce monsieur oui
j'y joue c'est valérie benaïm vous
pouvez venir une minute oui venez voir
qu'est-ce qui s'occupe qu'est-ce qui
s'occupe de cyril hanouna normalement
c'est vous mokhtar qu'est ce qui se
passe ce monsieur n'est pas cyril
hanouna ces messieurs n'est pas cyril
hanouna
c'est le tout celle touchée le nom mais
il lui ressemble et celui mokhtar il est
où cyril hanouna ce monsieur est un
artiste transformiste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
même que c'est
c'est la même barbe regardez c'est la
même barbe touche et toucher la balle et
cyril hanouna il est beau le monsieur
n'est pas bon là c'est pas sérieux la
menace est pas cyril hanouna
mais je vous assure regardez regardez
les cheveux mes cheveux c'est non c'est
non c'est pas la même texture même la
voix c'est pas lui le corps le corps
filet ou cyril mais je sais mais c'est
un artiste transformiste ou le
connaissais pas chaque touche comment il
s'appelle regard des embauches mais je
ne sais pas comment il s'appelle un an
c'est luis roca sa voix à la voir ça en
tout cas ça c'est magnifique
oui merci bien moooh gilou alors nous
sommes dans la victoire